Speaker 1: All right, let's take a few
minutes to look at this, the rest of this
very dangerous interview that Donald Trump gave
to Real America's voice. You might recall that
about a half hour ago where 40 minutes ago, at
the start of the show or earlier in the show,
we looked at another request from Donald Trump
to Vladimir Putin. Putin's invading Ukraine,
and Trump says to Putin, Hey, can you
get me some dirt on Hunter Biden? That
happened yesterday. It's not 2017 or whenever
it was 2016, 2015. Trump saying, Hey, Russia,
if you're listening, this interview in
total was absolutely sick and disgusting.
Very clearly, Donald Trump extremely
sensitive about the small size of his
crowd on Saturday at his rally. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Sounds it. They lie. They cheat.
I've never seen anything like it. I never
knew it was that corrupt. I knew it was.
It was a lot of fake stuff going on. But since I
got into politics, I had a lot of media before,
you know, with The Apprentice and all
the things I've done in the business,
but I've never seen anything like it. You
cannot. They will not write a good story.
I have great poll numbers that'll put them
out. I have great things happening, like super
Speaker 1: confident alpha male hang guys.
Speaker 2: Just the other day, we had a fantastic
rally in Georgia. Some guy from I think it's NPR
or something I never heard of. The person said,
Oh, the rally wasn't well attended. The sheriff
just said it was twenty five thousand people. He
said it was a couple of thousand people, or less
than 5000 people. We had less than 5000 people and
we had 5000 people in the first few rows. I think
you were there. You people and your cameraman
would just, yes, sir. That rally was packed.
Speaker 1: They said, Sir, the rally was just
absolutely packed. So it was a very it was.
It was the smallest crowd for a Trump rally,
I think, in six years. And Trump very, very
sensitive about it. Trump continuing to play
up the story of inflation and supply chain issues,
but playing it up with just weird talking points
that don't make any sense. And of course, it's
very clear that Trump doesn't have any idea how
the real world works. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: An example supply chain. You go to
a store, they don't have bread. We're like a
third world country. They don't have things.
You go to buy something at Tiffany. You're going
to buy something at a hardware store. Hi. Hello.
Speaker 1: I love that. It's like, Listen, I
don't know that you've ever been to a grocery
store to buy bread, and I don't know that you
have ever been to a hardware store looking for
a drywall anchor. But in the middle, he says,
if you go to Tiffany, which is not exactly,
you know, relatable to most people,
Speaker 2: they don't have a product.
They say even me. When I order things like
for furnishings, for a building or some
Speaker 1: Trump's regularly
ordering tchotchkes off of Amazon.
Speaker 2: They say it's going to take nine
months to get it used to be like same day service
supply chain. We never even heard the term.
Speaker 1: Now, of course we did. Many of us,
you know, in the business field, we back, even
in business school, we would do case studies
on the supply chain. But Trump says we never
heard it before. This is maybe my favorite part
of the interview. Dave Weigel is a reporter who's
a friend of the show. He's a really good guy. I've
known Dave Weigel for a really long time here.
Trump doesn't like what Dave Weigel had to say.
Speaker 2: Check this out. Alex, you can't even
get into him. The people get this, and I have to
put up with this. I had The Washington Post write
a story that a rally I was giving in an arena
that the arena was empty. It was a man that
you know very well in The Washington Post.
And it was empty about 10 hours before
Speaker 1: him, and he will eventually name
Dave. So just keep listening to sitting there.
Speaker 2: And he showed an empty that thousands
of people outside waiting to get in. And then
they came and he had to do an apology, actually,
because the arena was packed. And you know
who went after the people in the arena because
they saw it, that it was an empty arena and you
couldn't. I mean, they used the steps as seats.
It was thousands and thousands of people,
right? More than far more than an NBA game.
His name was Weigel, or a wiggle for The
Washington Post, and he had to do an apology.
Speaker 1: I can assure you that Dave
Weigel is absolutely loving this. Trump also
says Democrats are quote, bad on religion.
Speaker 2: But it's like Florida, everyone said,
Oh, Florida, Florida. But I won in like
a landslide. The way you win is you have
to win them because when they have no voter
I.D., defund the police sanctuary cities, weak
military, will they raise your taxes? No energy
independence, all things that were all done.
Speaker 1: And they're against it now,
what is really interesting about this
is every single one of those claims we could
actually go through them. You know, one at a time,
Trump actually says, if we look at the subtitles
here, we have no voter ID. Well, actually,
there's plenty of places that have voter ID. The
issue is the implementation of voter ID defund the
police. No serious Democrats are actually looking
to defund the police. Sanctuary cities these are
municipal decisions that are made, and it doesn't
have anything to do with the federal government,
as Donald Trump claims that it does weak military.
Democrats keep rubber stamping military budgets
just like Do Republicans raise your taxes? Well,
not on people earning under $400000. And then,
of course, no energy independence. We produced
as much oil as we used in 2020 and also in 2021
under Joe Biden. I mean, all of these things are
not true, but his followers don't care that we're
all done.
Speaker 2: And they're against it,
bad on religion, bad on the Second Amendment,
paranoia, I'll think of it, they said, I'm
going to have a close race in Texas, but they're
against God, right? Just look at it. God, guns and
oil. I want Texas in I'm in a record, right?
Speaker 1: No, there was no record, actually.
Trump won Texas by quite a small margin for a
Republican, and it's this is the difficulty when
we say we just got to talk to these people, David,
just talk to these people and they'll see reason.
There are so many lies upon lies. I mean,
it's a throwaway in here, right? It's it's
a throwaway that I won Texas by a record. No, you
didn't. And it's not even the point of the actual
story. And so it becomes almost a physical
impossibility to unwind the lie upon lie upon lie.
One last clip here, and this is an interesting
policy thing. It started to be floated by
Matt Gates, the radical Republican congressman
under investigation for child sex trafficking.
Trump's former propagandist, Steve Bannon, has
talked about this. What if Republicans win the
House in 2022 in a few months, and then they
make Donald Trump the speaker of the House?
Because remember, you don't have to be a member
of Congress to be speaker of the House. Trump
actually says here, he's not interested in it.
Speaker 4: Oh, I want to ask a follow up while
we're talking about Congress.
Because these comments went viral
at the rally when Congressman Matt Gaetz brought
up you being nominated for Speaker of the House.
And your reaction intrigued me because
I couldn't tell one way or the other how
you felt about that. Your reaction?
Speaker 2: No, I think that it's not
something I wanted. A lot of people bring
it up and spread up all the time. You know,
it's not something I want to do. I want to look at
what's happening and then we're going to be doing
something else. No, it's not something I would be
Speaker 1: doing something else. You guys know why
Trump really doesn't want to be so OK.
His ego would not allow him to go from
having been president to being speaker of
the House. Fine. I totally get that. That
makes sense from an ego standpoint. Being
speaker of the House actually is more work
the way Trump would have to be doing it and
compared to the way Trump did the job of the
president. Because as president, in theory,
you would imagine being presidents are very,
very busy job. Trump had hours of TV time in
the morning, and then he would often spend the
afternoon tweeting before he was banned from
Twitter and so on and so forth. So it would
be a lot more work for Trump to be the speaker
of the House, but interesting that he's saying,
I just don't want to do it, and that basically
puts an end to that discussion. I mean, if Trump
doesn't want to do it, he doesn't want to do it.
So there's Trump very strange interview. His mood
seems sort of altered and granting just any old
interview these days. And I think that we will
soon see a greater level of involvement in the
2022 midterms. And it's really important that
the Left have a strategy in place because
otherwise they actually as cartoonishly
ignorant as they are, they're going to run
away with it unless the left gets it together